gewalt in einer kita gewalt mit worten
aber offenbar auch körperliche gewalt im
brandenburgischen neuruppin da klagen
eltern jetzt an die eichhörnchen kita
dort wird zur albtraum kita
[Musik]
misshandlungen mobbing und demütigung
demütigungen an kindern eltern berichten
von schlimmen zuständen von mobbing und
gewalt in der kita eichhörnchen im
brandenburgischen neuruppin sollen
kinder von erzieherinnen gemobbt
gedemütigt und sogar misshandelt worden
sein mit blauen flecken und
hautabschürfungen kamen die kinder nach
der kita nach hause die eltern
fassungslos es gab nämlich ein vorfall
die nicht draußen beobachtet habe weil
mein kind dass mein kind an einer
erzieherin einen großen bogen gemacht
hat jetzt auch da wurde auch sehr
läufern kita-leitung auskennst weil sie
nicht der norm entsprechen hat wie geht
das normale kind das waren auch
teilweise wenn meine tochter am anfang
zwangsstörungen
vorzufinden was in der kita im märz
hinaus geprägt hatte mein sohn ist
kilometer schafft mit der so viel
energie der kann den ganzen tag bleiben
ohne zu schlafen zwischendurch und in
der kita wurde er gezwungen zu schlafen
die haben seine also sehen damit
hingelegt und haben ihre hand auf seinem
rücken erhalten damit er unten bleibt
und haben die fast jeden tag mit ihm
gemacht bestimmt sechs monate lang und
dadurch halt mein kind angst nicht ins
bett gekriegt weil er immer angst hatte
dass sie ihm den rücken festhalte und
ihn wirklich zwingend zu schlagen
furchtbare zustände von denen die eltern
berichten ein vater schreibt auf
facebook
es sind viele schlimme dinge in dieser
einrichtung passiert viele kinder
mussten monate oder jahre darunter
leiden eltern sind zusammengebrochen
weinend viele eltern sind verzweifelt
und wütend und wissen nicht was sie tun
sollen und dann
einige kinder essen nicht mehr viele
kinder weinen im schlaf einige kinder
machen in die hose monate oder
vielleicht auch jahre hat niemand etwas
gesagt oder geholfen
bis vor kurzem endlich jemand die
stadtverwaltung informiert die hat
reagiert und die leiterin der kita
eichhörnchen und ihre stellvertreterin
mit sofortiger wirkung vom dienst
suspendiert ihnen die kündigung
ausgesprochen und den beiden frauen
hausverbot erteilt jetzt konkret um rund
22 personen die beiden leitungskräfte
den vorwürfen zu teil geworden sind und
wird die entsprechende maßnahmen hier
getroffen worden sind ich möchte aber
betonen an der stelle stehen keine
vorwürfe sexuellen missbrauchs im raum
sollten tatsächlich sind es andere dinge
dinge wie
körperverletzungsdelikte dinge wie
nötigung oder eben auch also etwas wie
die verletzung der fürsorgepflicht für
die eltern steht fest auch die anderen
erzieherinnen haben sich mitschuldig
gemacht sie hätten von den
misshandlungen gewusst und nichts gesagt
ich bin kam der schreck wie wie kühl
dort die behörden gerade darüber
gesprochen haben gewaltvorwürfe an der
kita und dann liest man das so vor wie
ja wie als wenn es um ja irgend eine
neue verordnung geht unglaublich mit
reporterin an die garage ist genau dort
vor dieser albtraum kita jetzt in
neuruppin annika ich kann mir gar nicht
vorstellen wie das ist wenn man da heute
früh sein kind hingebracht hat seine
kleine tochter oder seinen kleinen sohn
aber ganz viele eltern haben das
tatsächlich gemacht heute früh um sechs
hat die kita wieder eröffnet wie war das
mit welchem gefühl
mit ganz ganz großer verunsicherung sei
denn die eltern wissen tatsächlich noch
gar nicht so viel sie wissen nicht wie
lange ich hier etwas passiert und was
genau ist eigentlich passiert ein
elternabend der angesetzt wurde wurde
spontan abgesagt das heißt auch viele
eltern wissen noch gar nicht welches
ausmaß das hier überhaupt hatte wenn mit
einer mutter gesprochen wird gesagt sie
bringt ihr kind jetzt zur kita sieht ein
okay es gefühl sie weiß dass eben diese
zwei betroffenen erzieherin entbunden
wurden von ihrem job aber natürlich ist
immer immer noch diese ungewissheit da
aber wir haben auch mit einer anderen
mutter gesprochen die zwei ihrer kinder
auf dieser kita hatte die erste gute
erfahrungen gemacht hat und dann sehr
schlechte weil daneben die kita-leitung
gewechselt hat und da können jetzt
einmal ganz kurz reinhören
ja also mein sohn ist keine grünen
sachen also auch keine erbsen teil
brokkoli und so weiter und er wurde an
dem tag am stuhl festgebunden und ihm
wurde der mund zugedrückt und dann wurde
ihm das essen quasi rein gezwungen bis
alles leer war und seitdem ist er halt
auch wirklich nicht mehr mit löffel und
möchte auch wirklich gar nichts grünes
mehr auf dem teller haben oder so
generell nichts grünes mehr an essen
sehen ein fehler kann ich so unbedingt
eine gut schildern was da los ist und
wartet größte problem war aber er hat
schon von situationen erzählt sowie halt
mit der tüv situation und die schlaf
situation hat er jeden tag halt
geschildert dass sie ihn auf die
matratze gedrückt haben und ich wirklich
runter gedrückt haben mit der hand und
er wirklich schlafen musste obwohl mein
sohn can mittagsschlaf trend ist und das
wussten die er sollte nicht lange in der
kita
janika das was diese mutter da berichtet
ist wirklich der blanke horror für mich
auch selbst als zweifache mutter
wenn ich meine kinder in den
kindergarten bringen morgens dann denke
ich sie sind da hoffentlich gut
aufgehoben so was passiert nicht unter
schlimmen und das hat diese mutter auch
gerade erwähnt ist ja auch dass die
kinder zum teil so klein sind dass sie
es zu hause nicht berichten können also
man erfährt es vielleicht gar nicht die
kinder sind dann einfach nur
traumatisiert irgendwie psychisch
gestört aber man weiß gar nicht was ist
da genau vorgefallen wie kann es denn
überhaupt sein dass da so viele jahre
nichts passiert ist das jetzt erst
jemand durch kraft und sagt die
erzieherin und die kita-leiterin sind
ihren job los warum erst jetzt
die eltern sind tatsächlich total
entsetzt weil sie sagen ihre kinder
haben jetzt noch
belastungsstörungen von dieser situation
von diesen situationen an dieser kita
und man hat wohl lange darum gekämpft
darauf aufmerksam zu machen ist sogar
ins rathaus gefahren hat mit menschen
gesprochen und hat gesagt hier stimmt
was nicht hier läuft was falsch mit
unseren kindern und man hat sie wohl
ausgelacht und wieder weggeschickt das
hat das war schon vor einigen jahren der
fall man hat es schon vor zwei jahren
probiert und es wurde eben nichts
gemacht jetzt wurde sehr schnell
jetzt wurden kam die konsequenzen sehr
sehr schnell aber trotzdem sind die
eltern natürlich absolut bestürzt weil
sie eben nicht wissen wie lange es hier
eigentlich schon was passiert und einige
sprechen sogar von zwölf jahren also das
ist eine sehr lange zeit von der wir
hier sprechen zwölf jahre die so etwas
passiert ist offenbar dort in europa und
ganz lange hat niemand drüber geredet
oder hat niemand gehandelt das ist ein
unglaublicher fall für uns bleibt unsere
bild reporterin annika rasch genau da
dran an der albtraum kita von neuruppin
und an der aufklärung dort in diesem
städtchen im brandenburgischen danke dir
[Musik]